مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض نبداها بالعناوين
روسيا واوكرانيا تتبادلان الاتهامات بشان
تفجير سد نفايا كخوفك جنوب اوكرانيا
بعد نحو ثمانيه اعوام من اغلاقها السفاره
الايرانيه في الرياض تفتح ابوابها بعد
استئناف العلاقات
نحو 800 الف ناخب كويتي يدلون باصواتهم في
انتخابات مجلس الامه
ايضا
الجمارك السعوديه تعلن واحباطه ثلاث
محاولات لتهريب اكثر من 650 الف حبه
كبتاجون مخدره
وبعد تكهنات الناس اشغلت الوسط الرياضي
الفرنسي كريم بنزيما لاعبا في الاتحاد
السعودي لثلاثه مواسم
دعت وزاره الخارجيه الاوكرانيه مجلس الامن
الدولي الاجتماع عاجل لمناقشه الهجوم على
سد نفايا كخوفك في جنوب اوكرانيا ودعت
ايضا الوزاره في بيان مجلس محافظي الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه التابعه للامم
المتحده الى مناقشه الحادث وطالبت بفرض
عقوبات دوليه جديده على روسيا خاصه فيما
يتعلق بمجال صناعه الصواريخ والقطاع
النووي الروسي
وكان سد نفايا كخوفك قد تعرض لاستهداف
تسبب بارتفاع منسوب المياه في نهر الديني
برو وانخفاض ايضا المياه المخزنه في السد
بعد توقف اربع تربينات وحضرت السلطات
فيخرسون السكان بالعزياء المنخفضه من
المدينه للاخلاء باسرع وقت ممكن والبحث عن
ماوى على ارض مرتفعه بسبب الفيضانات وقالت
السلطاته ان هناك سته عشر الف شخص بما
اسمته بالمنطقه الحرجه على بعد 100 ميل في
ش مال الشرقي تقع محطه النوويه التي تعتمد
على مخزونات المياه في سد نفاياكا خوفكا
في عمليات التبريد اللازمه لمنع كارثه
النوويه ويعتبر سد قناه حيويه لنقل المياه
من نهر جنيبرو لشبه جزيره القرم واكد
مسؤولون ان المناطق الشماليه مهدده بالعطش
وكانت السلطات الاوكرانيه اعلنت عن وجود
تسريبات زيوت محركات اثر انفجار سد نفايا
كخوفكا وقالت مستشاره مدير مكتب رئيس
اوكرانيا داريا في حسابها على التليجرام
ان 150 طنا من زيت المحركات تسربت الى نهر
دينيبرو بعد انفجار سد كخوفك لتوليد
الطاقه في جنوب اوكرانيا موضحه ان هناك
المزيد من خطر حدوث التسربات اخرى تؤثر
سلبا على البيان ومضيفه بان هدف الروس من
تفجير السد وضرب القطاع الزراعي الاوكراني
وازاحه اوكرانيا كمنافس وابتزاز العالم
بازمات الجوع
الجانبي وصف السفير الروسي لدى فينا
ميخائيل اوليانوب في مقابله للعربيه اتهام
بلاده باستهداف المنشات النوويه بالامر
السخيف موضح ان المصلحه المشتركه تحتيم
الضمان امن منشاه زابروج النوويه
لا يحتاج الامر للتاكيد على ان كل الجهود
ستبدل لضمان الامن النووي والحديث بان
روسيا تعرض المنشات النوويه للخطر هو امر
سخيف نحن اسسنا الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه وبالطبع دائما ما نتعاون مع
الوكاله ونتوقع ان تتعاون الوكاله معنا
وهذا التعاون يحصل بصوره دوريه ومن ضمنها
حول منشاه زابوريا وبدوره اتهم السفير
اوكرانيا انتون كورن بيتش خلال مداخله
امام محكمه العدل الدوليه في لاهاي روسيا
بتفجير سد نفايا كخوفكا وصفها بانها دوله
رابيه
لا يمكن لروسيا ان تهزمنا في ساحه المعركه
لذا فهي تستهدف البنيه التحتيه المدنيه
لمحاوله اجبارنا على الخضوع اليوم فجرت
روسيا سدا رئيسيا يقع في نوفا مما تسبب في
اجلاء عدد كبير من المدنيين واضرار مائيه
كبيره وتهديد سلامه محطه زابوريج النوويه
ان افعال روسيا هي افعال دوله ارهابيه
معتديه
هذا ونشرت وسائل اعلام اوكرانيه صورا
بالاقمار الاصطناعيه لسد نوفاك خوفك
فيخرسون جنوبيه اوكرانيا قبل وبعد تدميره
وتظهر صور انغمار المنطقه المحيطه بالسد
بالمياه واكدت السلطات المواليه لروسيا في
خرسون ان منسوب المياه في المدينه وصل الى
اكثر من 11 مترا وتتبادل روسيا واوكرانيا
الاتهامات حول الهجوم على سد نفائق خوفك
الكريملين من جانبه قال ان الرئيس
فلاديمير بوتين تلقى احاطه حول ما حدث في
نفايا كخوفكا رفض الكريم للتهامات
اوكرانيا لروسيا بالمسؤوليه عن تدمير السد
واكد ان تدميره مرتبط بفشلها هجمات
اوكرانيا المضاد واضاف بيسكو بان الهجوم
على السد متعمد من جانب كييف لحرمان شبه
جزيره القرم من المياه
معنى من موسكو مراسل العربيه عبد الجواد
الرشد ومن دانياتك مراسل العربيه رائد
الاغبر اهلا بكم نبدا مع كرائد ما هي اخر
التداعيات اجراء تفجير سد منوفيه
الحديث لي اظن لم اسمع جيدا عموما خالد
منذ الصباح الباكر والتطورات مستمره بخصوص
قصف السد وتدمير اجزاء منها الاجزاء
العلويه التي تسببت بفيضان المياه وتسريب
المياه ما تسبب
فيضانات على ضفتي النهر نهر دينيبرو الذي
يمتد في المنطقه الجنوبيه من اوكرانيا
ويفصل القوات الاوكرانيه عن القوات
الروسيه ومناطق سيطره الجيش الروسي ومناطق
سيطرت الاوكرانيين الحديث عن ان هذا السد
يعني
غمر 600 منزل
يعني في الضفه الشماليه التي تتبع لروسيا
وان عمليات الاجلاء بدات بالفعل الحديث عن
اكثر من 20 الف نسمه تقطن في هذه الناحيه
السلطات
نشرت على
التليفونات
ضروره تحضير امتعه ووثائق
وطعام لمده ثلاثه ايام يكفي على الاقل
ولنقل المواطنين وبدات هذه العمليه بالفعل
عن طريق مركبات خاصه تنقل
تفضل
طيب يبدو ان الاتصال انقطع مع رائد اذهب
الى موسكو الى عبد الجواد الرشد
وسؤل لك ايضا عن اخر التفاعلات والتطورات
والتداعيات ايضا من وجهه نظر موسكو
مرحبا خالد على الصعيد الرسمي ان يتحدثوا
عن ان هذا الفعل بضربه محطه نظرك هو تخريب
متعمد ووصفته
الارهابي وتحدثت بان كيف ستدفع الثمن في
القريب العاجل بما يخص هذه الضربه على
الصعيد الرسمي في حكومه تلك المنطقه في
حكومه نظرك خفقا المواليه لروسيا الحديث
يدور عن ان المدينه الان تملاها المياه
هناك انجراف للعديد من المنازل والفيضانات
طبعا تملا الشوارع هو معظم المناطق
السكنيه بالاضافه الى الاراضي الزراعيه هي
ضربه من العيار الثقيل لذلك الاقليم
الكثير من القرى والمناطق السكنيه
المجاوره لضفتي هذا النهر تتعرض الان
فيضانات في اخر الاحصاءات والارقام
الرسميه مستوى المياه في البحيره المجاوره
لمحطه زاباروجي النوويه وهو الملف الاهم
في هذه القضيه والاخطر ان صح التعبير
مستوى هذه المياه انخفض مترين ونصف المتر
تقريبا حسب روايه السلطات الرسميه هناك
المواليه لروسيا من المتوقع خالد خلال
الساعات الخمس القادمه ان ينخفض مستوى
المياه الى سبعه امتار ما يعني حسب
القراءه التحليليه العلميه للعديد من
الخبراء ان كانوا فيروس اطم او ان كانوا
في جامعات التقنيات العلميه في روسيا بما
يخص القضايا ومحطاء والمحطات النوويه بان
هذا المستوى مقبول لعمليه تبريد المفاعلات
في محطه النوويه لكن المخيف في حال انخفض
المستوى اكثر من ذلك الكثير من القراءات
تتحدث بانه يجب الانتظار هذه الفتره وهي
الساعات الخمس الست القادمه لمعرفه ما الى
اين ستؤول اليه الامور وكيف هي الطريقه
الافضل للتصرف وهل المحطه بحاجه الى طرق
تبريد في حال خرج مستوى المياه على
المستوى المتوقع الذي كان يعمل به هذا بما
يخص كل التصريحات الرسميه ما زالت طبعا ما
زال المواطنون من تلك المناطق يقومون بنشر
العديد من مقاطع الفيديو والاخبار تظهر
طوفان العديد من المنازل فوق النهر الجارف
هذه المياه طبعا تاكل الاخضر واليابس هناك
معظم هذه التقارير تتحدث عن اضرار ماديه
بالغه ولم يتم التاكيد حتى هذه اللحظه عن
مصرع اي شخص خلال عمليه الغرق او عمليه
الفيضانات ايضا خالد طبعا حكومه تلك
المنطقه تتحدث بان هذه الضربه يعني هي
فاعله بشكل كبير وقد تؤدي الى اضرار جسيمه
في المنطقه قد تؤدي الى حرقه والغاء يعني
ومنع معظم الاراضي الزراعيه من الاستثمار
خلال هذه الفتره لكن لن تكون كارثيه على
المناطق المجاوره لذلك طبعا مدينه
تاخيرسون حتى هذه اللحظه وبالرغم من ان
مناطقها المجاوره للنهر مملوءه الان
بالمياه الا ان المدينه حتى هذه اللحظه
تعيش وضعها الطبيعي ولا خطر يشكله تدافع
يعني
تشكله موجات المياه والفيضانات في تلك
المنطقه كل الاحاديث الان في الشارع
الروسي في الداخل على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي معظم البرامج التلفزيونيه تتحدث
عن هذا الموضوع تفضل خالي
ما حجم الاثر المرصود حتى الان في المناطق
يعني المحيطه بخير
المتضرره الاكثر حرجا كيف ايضا تعمل
السلطات على الاخلاق اخلاء سكان هذه
المناطق
بدايه لابد من الاشاره الى ان الضرر يصل
الى مقاطعتي خرسون وزبروجي لان
السد في نوفيكا خوفك هو اطراف خرسون لكنه
يخدم محطه النوويه والحديث عن الهدف بقطع
التيار الكهربائي عن محطه زبروج النوويه
بهدف تسريب اشعاعات نوويه حسب المحللين في
مقاطعه زابروجي ايضا السلطات فيزا خالد
قالت بان
تعمد الاجانب الاوكراني اذا تذكر قبل
اسابيع قطع الكهرباء عن هذه المحطه
الكهرومائيه من اجل رفع منسوب المياه من
اربعه عشر مترا الى سبعه عشر ونصف وذلك
ليسبب بعض الضربه ضررا اكبر
منازل والمقيمين طرف الان طرف الانفصاليين
اذا صح التعبير او الم لروسيا وكذلك
الخنادق الروسيه لان روسيا منذ اشهر وهي
تبني تبني خنادق دفاعيه اظهرت صور
فيديوهات المقاتلين الروس رغم الفيضانات
يحافظون على مواقعهم في تلك الخنادق التي
باتت غارقه بفيضانات النهر هذا من جانب
الجانب الاخر المحطه النوويه قالت السلطات
في زبروجي والمسؤولين عن المحطه قالوا بان
المحطه معده
وجاهزه لصد حتى هجومات نوويه لو فكر
الجانب الاوكراني بقصف المحطه نفسها فان
المحطه مستعده لاي ضربه صاروخيه كما كانت
على الجسر فان هناك اتهامات متبادله
مستمره كما اسلفتم خالد وحتى الان لم يعرف
من قصف هذا الجسر وتسبب بكل هذه الاضرار
شكرا لكم اريد الاغبر من دانيات كوا عبد
الجواد الرشد من موسكو
[موسيقى]
هذا وقد حذر الامير العام لخلفي الناتو
يانس من ان تدمير اسد نفايق كخوفك في جنوب
اوكرانيا يعرض الاف المدنيين للخطر ووصف
استهداف السد بانه عمل شائن ويثبت مجددا
وحشيه الهجوم الروسي
لقد غيرت الحرب العدوانيه غير المبرره
التي تشنها روسيا ضد اوكرانيا بئتنا
الامنيه على المدى الطويل لقد مزقت روسيا
سلامه في اوروبا واليوم يعارض تدمير سد
كخوفكا الاف المدنيين للخطر ويتسبب في
اضرار بيئيه جسيمه هذا عمل مشين ويظهر مره
اخرى وحشيه الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
استكمالا لعمليه تنفيذ الاتفاقيه المبرمه
بين السعوديه وايران تفتتح اليوم في
الرياضه السفاره الايرانيه بحضور ممثلين
من وزارتي الخارجيه السعوديه والايرانيه
يتم افتتاح بعد ثلاثه اشهر من توقيع
الاتفاق السعودي الايراني لاستئناف
العلاقات بينهما برعايه صينيه وسيعاد
او فتح مبنى السفاره السابق الذي كان
مغلقا لسنوات بعدما تم ترميمه بالكامل
مؤخرا
ان امام السفاره الايرانيه في الرياض ينضم
الينا مراسل العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي
عبد المحسن ما هي او كيف ترصد الاجواء
الان
نعم خالد بالفعل تواجدنا هنا منذ الساعه
العاشره لرصد ابرز التحركات امام السفاره
الايرانيه استعدادا الافتتاحها اليوم
الساعه السادسه بتوقيت الرياض حيث شاهدنا
العديد من التحركات للمره الاولى خلال
سبعه سنوات كانت هذه السفاره مغلقه ولا
يوجد فيها اي تحركات الى انه اليوم وبعد
سنوات من الاغلاق تعود الحركه الى السفاره
الايرانيه حيث رصدنا تواجد العديد من
الدبلوماسيين والعاملين في السلك
الدبلوماسيه الايراني تحديدا في السفاره
الايرانيه يتجولون في السفاره ويستعدون
لعمليه الاحتفال التي ستقام اليوم والتي
قامت السفاره الايرانيه بتقديم دعوات الى
مختلف السفارات المختلفه تحديدا اعضاء
السلك الدبلوماسي في حي السفارات هنا حيث
تتواجد العديد من السفرات الاجنبيه
بالاضافه الى ذلك سيحضر مسؤولين من وزاره
الخارجيه السعوديه ومسؤولين من وزاره
الخارجيه الايرانيه بحضور هذا الاحتفال
وبدء مراسم رفع العلم الايراني فوق ساريه
السفاره الايرانيه هنا في في حي السفارات
هذا الاحتفال خالد ياتي بعد عمليه
نقل او تبادل
للسفارات او للمسؤولين من السفرات تحديدا
الوفود الفنيه التي قدمت من طهران الى هنا
للاشراف على عمليه افتتاح السفاره
وتجهيزها لبدء عملها الدبلوماسي تنفيذا
لاتفاق السعودي الايراني الصيني الذي عقد
في بكين حيث لم يستغرق وقتا طويلا حتى تم
تجهيز السفاره بشكل كامل والاعلان عن بدء
العمل فيها بشكل رسمي اليوم بالاضافه الى
القنصليه الايرانيه في جده وايضا عوده
ممثليه ايران لدى منظمه التعاون الاسلامي
في في جده بالاضافه الى ذلك خالد يتم
الحديث لانه السفير الايراني الذي المعين
من قبل السلطات الايرانيه لدى السعوديه
سيكون حاضرا في هذه
الاحتفاليه حتى الان يتم التاكيد بشكل
كامل وقاطع حضور السفير ولكن تم التاكيد
من قبل وسائل الاعلام ايرانيه رسميه عن
اسم هذا السفير وهنا نتحدث عن السفير
الايراني الذي تم تعيينه من قبل
ايران وهو علي رضا عنايه علي رضا عنايه
كان قد تقلد مناصب عديده في وزاره
الخارجيه الايرانيه وكان مندوبا وقائما
بالاعمال في جده بالاضافه الى انه كان
سفيرا لدى الكويت لايران لدى الكويت وهو
يشغل حاليا منصب مساعد وزير الخارجيه
الايراني لشؤون الخليج العربي هذا الاسم
تم تداوله بشكل رسمي من قبل وسائل الاعلام
ايرانيه ولكن لم يتم الاعلان بشكل رسمي من
قبل وزاره الخارجيه الايرانيه عن هذا
الاسم وتعيينه وبعد ذلك تقديم اوراقه الى
اوراقه الى السعوديه
كممثلا رسميا وسفيرا لايران في السعوديه
بعد افتتاح سفارتها شكرا لك عبد المحسن
الحربي من الرياض
اكدت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه التزامها
واشنطن بتعزيز شركتها الامنيه مع السعوديه
بما في ذلك المبيعات الدفاعيه والتدريبات
المشتركه ومكافحه انتشار الصواريخ
والطيران المسير لدى جهات غير حكوميه
وقالت الوزاره في بيان حول العلاقات بين
واشنطن قبيل زياره وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
للمملكه ان التعاون مع السعوديه من اجل
الضمان الاستقرار الاقليمي يظل احضار
ركائز علاقتنا الثنائيه اضافت ان الشراكه
الامنيه بين البلدين قائمه على الاهتمام
المشترك بامن منطقه الخليج ومنع اي قوه
اجنبيه او اقليميه من تهديد المنطقه
تلقى رئيس مجلس السياده الانتقالي الفريق
اول ركن عبد الفتاح البرهان اليوم اتصالا
هاتفيا من وزير الخارجيه السعودي الامير
فيصل ابن فرحان وفق بيان صادر عن مجلس
السياده البرهان خلال اتصال هاتفي اكد على
ضروره التزام قوات الدعم السريع بالخروج
من المستشفيات ومنازل المواطنين واخلاء
الجرحى وفتح المسارات الانسانيه حتى يحقق
منبر جدا نجح
الرابعه بعد قليل
23 مرشحه يونافسنا على مقاعد النواب في
انتخابات مجلس الامه الكويتي 2023
اهلا بكم من جديد الى الكويت حيث انطلقت
صباح اليوم عمليه الاقتراع الانتخابات
مجلس الامه 2023 والتي تستمر الاثنتي عشره
ساعه في نحو 108 مركزا يتنافس في هذه
الانتخابات 207 مرشحين ومرشح وهو العدد
الاقل منذ عام 2008 تتارجح في هذه
الانتخابات ترون الناخبين في رغبتهم
بالمشاركه وعدمها ويتوجه لان قرابه 794
الف ناخب ونابغ وناخب لادلاء باصواتهم
لمتابعه تنضم الينا من الكويت مراسله
العربيه شاهد المتروك شاهد حياك الله كيف
تسير عمليه
التصويت والانتخاب
نعم خالد يعني فتحت ابواب اللجان ومراكز
الاقتراع منذ الساعه الثامنه صباحا
وستستمر لغايه الساعه الثامنه مساء هي
لمده يوم واحد لمده 12 ساعه تتيح لي انه
خبين والذي يبلغ عددهم قرابه 794 الف ناخب
وناخب مستمره عمليه التصويت باقي من زمن
قرابه اربع ساعات
يعتبر طبعا الاقبال يعني ضعيف بالنسبه
لهذه الانتخابات
في بعض الدوائر لم يتجاوز 20% من عدد
الاجمالي لعدد الناخبين في تلك الدوائر
نحن نتواجد في الدائره الثانيه في احد
مراكز او لجان الاقتراع وتحديدا لجنه
اقتراع اصليه فيها عدد
الناخبات هي لجنه نسائيه طبعا عددنا خيبات
فيها 791 لكن لم تصوت حتى هذه اللحظه الا
باكثر بقليل من
ناخبه طبعا الملاحظه يعني من يعني القضاه
والقائمين في هذه اللجنه ان العدد الاكبر
او الاقبال من النساء ذوات العمر الاكبر
يعني يعني النساء التي توا بلغت اعمارهن
21 عام ما في اقبال من قبلهن للتصويت لكن
بشكل عام العمر الاكبر هم المقبلين على
عمليه التصويت عملنا استطلاعات راي مع
مختلف المواطنين والمواطنات ايضا عن يعني
رغبتهم في التصويت ام لا يعني ما الذي
شاهدوه من اختلاف هذه في هذه الانتخابات
التصويت حتى الذي يرغب في التصويت كان في
حاله احباط من كثره الانتخابات ايضا في
بعض الاشخاص لم يرغب بالتصويت بسبب يعني
قرب الاوقات ما بين الانتخابات الماضيه
وهذه الانتخابات لكن بشكل عام كان في رغبه
اكبر رغم ان كما ذكرت ان بعض الدوائر لم
يتجاوز نسبه التصويت فيها 20
% طبعا القاضي ايضا رجح ان سبب الاقبال
الضعيف الضعيف في هذه اللجنه وهذه الدائره
ربما بسبب الجو الحار يعني فتره الظهيره
الجو جدا حار يمكن راح يزيد عدد الناخبين
او الناخبات خلال فتره ما بعد الساعه خمس
يعني او المتبقي من الزمن ساعتين الى ثلاث
ساعات من اغلاق باب التصويت والاقتراع
شكرا جزيلا لك شاهد المتروك من الكويت
اذا العربيه استطلعت كاميرا او كاميرا
العربيه استطلعت الشعب الكويتيه حول
معيارهم للتصويت في الانتخابات التشريعيه
الكويتيه لاختيار اعضاء مجلس الامه 2023
الحقيقه هذه او خلينا نقول المعيار بشكل
عام في الانتخابات هو ان احنا نختار الشخص
الانسب يعني ان انا ما انتخب الشخص انه
مثلا بناء على صلاه قرابه على القناعه
يعني على اساس القناعه معياري حق
الانتخابات هذي اول شيء رؤيته شنو طرحه
شنو رؤيته تاريخ مثلا سياسي شنو عنده
اهداف راح اصوت له على بناء يعني شنو راح
يفيد البلد فيه كل العرس الانتخابي كل
مواطن له حق
ويختار العقول الافضل والاصلح للمنطقه ولا
المواطن ولديره وكل
حضر صندوق والاستثمارات العامه عبر حسابه
الرسمي على تويتر من اي تواصل ينتحل اسمه
بغرض طلب مبالغ او حوالات ماليه مؤكده على
ضروره عن الجرائم المعلوماتيه من خلال
تطبيق كلنا امن عشان صندوق الاستثمارات
العامه الى انه لا يقدم اي خدمات مباشره
للافراد
تم الاعلان يوم امس عن مشروع لتخسيس
الثمانيه من الانديه الرياضيه في السعوديه
وستاول ام ملكيتها الى صندوق الاستثمارات
العامه بنسبه 75% في المرحله الاولى
الانديه الرياضيه ليست الوجهه المحليه
الوحيده لاستثمارات صندوق الاستثمارات
العامه خلال العام الحالي فهناك عده
قطاعات واعده في المملكه استقطبت
استثمارات من الصندوق نستعرضها مع
ثلاث مرات في صندوق الاستثمارات العامه
السعودي في السوق المحلي تسلك مسار النمو
السريع فمنذ بدايه العام الحالي لا يتوانى
الصندوق عن ضخ الاستثمارات في الشركات
المدرجه والخاصه الاهتمام بالسوق المحلي
هو من اولويات الصندوق ف بالاضافه الى
الاستثمارات المسبقه يعتزم الصندوق دخت
تريليون ريال في المشاريع الجديده محليا
كما يستهدف زياده مساهمته في المحتوى
المحلي الى 60% في نهايه 20 25
استثمارات الصندوق لا تتوقف عند قطاع محدد
فكل قطاع واعد هو وجهه لهذه الاستثمارات
ولعل اخرها كان قطاع السلع الاستهلاكيه
والتجزئه حيث اشترى الصندوق حصه 30% في
شركه اسواق التميمي هذا الاستثمار سيسهم
في توسيع عمليات الشركه ونشاطها التجاري
اضافه للبحث في امكانيه تنفيذ طرح عام من
اولي للشركه ومن القطاعات البارزه التي
يستهدفها الصندوق قطاع الطيران فقد اعلن
عن تاسيس شركه طيران الرياض وهي ناقل جوي
وطني جديد بمعايير عالميه يسهم في تعزيز
منظومه الطيران السعوديه محليا وعالميا
وتهدف طيران الرياض لاطلاق رحلات تصل لي
اكثر من 100 وجهه حول العالم بحلول عشرين
ثلاثين وليس بعيدا عن قطاع الطيران والسفر
فقد وقع الصندوق اتفاقيه للاستحواذ على
30% من شركه المسافر التابعه لمجموعه سير
القابضه مقابل مليار وخمسمائه وخمسين
مليون ريال ويركز الصندوق ايضا على
السياحه الدينيه حيث اعلن عن تاسيس شركه
رؤى الحرم المكي الهادفه الى تطوير
مشاريعها تسهم في رفع الطاقه الاستيعابيه
لاستضافه زوار القديمين للمملكه كما اعلن
عن تاسيس شركه رؤى المدينه وهي شركه تطوير
عمراني تهدف الى تعزيز جاهزيه منطقه
المسجد النبوي لاستضافه عدد اكبر من
الزائرين للمدينه المنوره وفي ظل النهضه
العمرانيه التي تشهدها المملكه اطلق صندوق
شركه تطوير المربع الجديد بهدف بناء اكبر
واحدث داون تاون بالعالم في الرياض
المشروع يسهم في دعم الناتج المحلي غير
النفطي بما يصل الى 180 مليار واستحداث
334 الف فرصه عمل مباشره وغير مباشره كما
صندوق استثمارات في قطاع خدمات البناء
وتشييد بقيمه خمسه مليارات ريال في اربع
شركات محليه كما استحوذ بي اي اف على
ثلاثين في المئه من اسهم شركه تبريد
السعوديه التي تعمل على تطوير برامج تبريد
المستدامه لعدد من اكبر المشاريع في
المملكه التوسع في الاستثمار بالشركات
المحليه وانشاء اخرى جديده هو هدف
استراتيجي يسعى اليه الصندوق الذي يعتبر
الذراع الاساسيه لتحقيق رؤيه المملكه 20
اذا تاتي خطوات خطوات صندوق الاستثمارات
السعودي
في عام 2018 مع اعلان برنامج التخصيص
والضمن هنا ضمن رؤيه
يمثل اطلاق ولي العهد السعودي لمشروع
الاستثماري والتخسيس للانديه الرياضيه
واحدا من مساعد حكومه السعوديه لتعزيز
الدور القطاعي الخاص في تقديم الخدمات
الحكوميه والتي بدات مشاهدين مع اطلاق
برنامج التخصيص في العام 2018 وذلك ضمن
برنامج رؤيه 2030 ويسعى البرنامج مشاهدينا
الى تحديد الاصول والخدمات الحكوميه
القابله للتخصيص وتطوير الاليه والمنظومه
وتتمثل الاهداف الاستراتيجيه لبرنامج
التخصيص في تحرير الاصول المملوكه للدوله
امام القطاع الخاص وتخصيص خدمات حكوميه
محدده الحكومه السعوديه ومنذ العام 2018
حددت عددا من المستهدفات لبرنامج التخصيص
بنهايه العام 20 25 حيث تهدف الى تحقيق
ايرادات حكوميه غير نفطيه تصل الى 143
مليار ريال سعودي كما تهدف الى تحقيق 62
مليار ريال كاجمالي قيمه او كاجمال قيمه
الاستثمار الاستثمارات من عمليات الشراكه
بين القطاعين العام والخاص كما تهدف
الحكومه الى تحقيق 14 مليار ريال كاجمال
القيمه الماليه لكفاءه الانفاق الحكومي من
خلال عمليات الشراكه ولتحقيق ما سبق
مشاهدينا شهدت الفتره الماضيه عددا من
عمليات والاتفاقيات حيث تم اكتمال تخصيص
قطاع مطاحن الدقيق واتمام اتفاقيه مشروع
الجبيل ثلاثه ومشروع ينبع اربعه لانتاج
المياه المحلاه كما تم اتمام عقد المجموعه
الاولى من مبادره جذب الاستثمارات الخاصه
لتمويل انشاء مباني تعليميه
معي هنا في استديوهاتنا من الرياض رئيس
تحرير صحيفه المطلق الله يحييك يا مرحبا
نبدا معك من موضوع تخصيص الانديه في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
اين يمكن وضع هذا المشروع في اطار رؤيه
المملكه بالنسبه لما يتعلق بمشروع التخصيص
جميل جدا اول شيء رؤيه المملكه غيرت كثير
من المفاهيم اللي موجوده داخل البلد بشكله
باخر القطاع الرياضه على سبيل المثال كان
في الفتره الماضيه هو اشبه ما يكون تسليه
وترفيه اكثر ما هو نشاط اقتصادي فبالتالي
غيرت كثير من الرجال بعد ظهور رؤيه
المملكه
2030 بدات يعني في وفق رؤيه واضحه بدات
تهتم بكثير من القطاعات اعطيك مثال فقط
قبل ما ادخل حتى في الرياضه يعني على سبيل
المثال كانت كثير من القطاعات عندنا نوعا
ما عليها تركيز خلني اخذ السياحه على سبيل
المثال ما كان عليها تركيز كثير رمله
موجوده في البلد وفي اهتمامات او شيء لكن
ما كان عليها تركيز الان كيف ننظر للسياحه
اصبحت جاذبه كبير جدا للبلد اصبحت فيها
استثمارات فيها يعني كان واحد ما
مستهدفاتها ان يحقق 100 مليون زياره
سياحيه بحلول 2030 الان وصلنا قبل حتى على
سبع سنوات 93 مليون زياره سياحيه نقيس
عليها على الرياضه الان الرياضه كانت في
فتره الماضيه كانت معتمده على خلينا نقول
مجموعه من
رجال الاعمال واعضاء الشرف المهتمين بنادي
معينه او شيء لم تكن صناعه بحد ذاتها الان
لا اصبحت صناعه اصبحت يمكن من 2019 تقريبا
بعد
خلينا نقول اهتمام الدوله تحويل الرئاسه
الى وزاره دعم استراتيجيات الانديه
استقطاب لاعبين بشكل كبير جدا من الناس
تهتم فيها واصبحنا نستقطب حتى على سبيل
المثال زائري من خارج المملكه
لمشاهده مثلا فعاليات رياضيه سواء مثل
راديو البطولات الملاكم اللي كانت
البطولات الاخرى السوبر الايطالي
والاسباني فبدا الاهتمام فيها هذا
يساؤلد سيؤدي الى ضخ استثمارات اكبر داخل
البلد سيؤدي الى عمليه استقطاب مستثمرين
برا او حتى مستثمرين الداخل بدايه
الاهتمام فيها بشكل اكبر نحو مستهدفات
الرياض هذا ممكن نروح لموضوع مدى
الاستفاده يعني من موضوع التخسيس
في الدول وفي العالم بشكل عام تتجه الدول
الى التخصيص للاتفاق او او تعتمد عليه من
خلال وضع اليات شراكه بين القطاعين العام
الخاص والهدف هو يعني تعزيز جوده وكفاءه
الخدمات الموجهه للمجتمع السعوديه اليوم
لما تتجه الى التخصيص ليش الى اي مدى
بالفعل سيكون هناك انعكاس على جوده
الخدمات المقدمه لافراد المجتمع خليني
اقول لك على شيء يعني في فتره من فترات
يعني الفتره السابقه نتكلم كان اداره
الانديه والقطاع الرياضي هي هو اشبه ما
يكون بالهواء
طبعا كانت هو وبالتالي انا مهتم بنادي
معين فبالتالي يكون عندي هنا مثلا اهتمام
او حتى الادارين اللي موجودين الان لا
الوضع تغير الان في ظل وجود خلينا نقول
كائنات تجاريه استثماريه هدفها
القيمه على سبيل المثال من خلالها
الاستثمارات هذه تعزيز خلق فرص وظيفيه
استقطاب كوادر بشكل اكبر يعني للعمل داخل
هذه الانديه بدل عمليه الهواء مثلا بشكل
او باخر قبل كانت خلينا نقول الرغبه في
تشريع نادي معين هي اللي تحفزك لكن الان
لا حيكون الفلوس
والقدره على هذا الشخص هل هذا ممكن متمكن
ولا لا يعني ممكن على سبيل المثال ممكن
تلقاه يعني استقطاب شخص متمكن عنده قدره
كامله بس انه ترى يشجع نادي ثاني الان هنا
بس هنا تعزيز راس المال تعزيز القيمه
السوقيه تعزيز العمل بشكل او باخر لنا
يعني استشهاد في كثير من الدول العالم
التي تقدم مثلا او خصصت كثير من الانديه
سابقا او قطاع الرياضي في كيف حققت يعني
قيمه مضافه
هذا في الرياضه ممكن تكون حتى النتائج
سريعه استقطاب اسماء بارزه نجوم العوائد
اللي ممكن تعود ايضا على النادي وغيرها
لكن ماذا عن قطاعات الثانيه خلينا ناخذ
مثلا قطاع زي صحه تعليم وغيرها من الامور
وهي ايضا من القطاعات المستهدفه في برنامج
التخصيص كيف ممكن نتخيلوا نتوقع انه بتكون
هناك بالفعل فوائد كبيره المستوى البلد
وعلى مستوى المجتمع في في جوده الكفاءه
بعطيك مثال فقط للاستشهاد حتى المشاهدين
يقدروا يبنون عليه قيس قطاع الاتصالات
سابقا عندما كان تحت مظله الحكومه مثلا
وكيف تغير بعد ما خصخصته يعني كنت اقول
لحد الاخوان الرقم هذا اللي في جوالي مثلا
انا شاري بعشره الاف ريال الان تاخذ بمجان
وتاخذ خدمات اخرى
[ضحك]
بس كنا نحتاجه يعني ههه
فقس عليها في كل الاحوال في هذا الجانب
كيف ارتقت الخدمه كيف اصبح القطاع منتج
حتى في الناتج المحلي الاجمالي كيف توسع
في التوظيف توسع في الاستثمار في خلق
الفرص الاستثماريه في تعزيز حتى جذب
الاستثمار الخارجي يعني احنا عندنا الان
مثلا على سبيل الشركات الاتصالات انا هنا
اظرف مثال بما انك انت ضربت مثل بالصحه
والشيء عندنا شركه محليه يعني راس مال
كامل سعودي لكن عندنا شركتين لهم استثمار
خارجي سواء موبايلي مثلا وزين مثلا هذا لو
ما كانت هناك فرص استثماريه ما قدرت انك
تستقطب هالاستثمار الخارجي
عليه في قطاع الصحه في التعليم في اي مجال
كان في الرياضه الان انا اعتقد انها مرحله
يعني
تغير شامل في في الرياضه خلال فتره الجايه
بتغير منهجيه العمل بشكل اكبر بيحاول يخلق
حتى المتوقعه من ناحيه اقتصاديه على البلد
يعني البيان اللي طلع حدد لك حدد لك في
كبي ايز واضحه لعمليه الاشياء المتوقع انك
كيف ترفع قيمه الدوري السعودي من 4 مليار
تقريبا ريال الى 8 مليار ريال خلال فتره
قصيره هذا هو هذا واضح يعني عائد تقدر
تقيس عليه وتقدر تبني عليه حتى خلال فتره
الجايه فهذا تقدر شيء ملموس قبل كل حاجه
بتغيرنا هذيك اللي تشجعوه بعد اذا
استخطبوني يمكن اغير ههه طيب بس انا في
الصحابه يعني في الاعلام فخلقنا هنا يعني
رغم ان يعني الله يوفق ان شاء الله شكرا
لك
صحيفه يعطيك العافيه حياك تسلم
مستمره فيها بعد الفاصل
الجمارك السعوديه تعلن واحباط ثلاثه
محاولات لتهريب اكثر من 650 الف حبه
كبتاجون مخدر
اهلا بكم
وحبوب خاضعه للرقابه الطبيه عثر عليها
مخبا في ارساليات وردت الى المملكه عبر
عدد من المنافذ الجمركيه
[موسيقى]
اعلن الامين العام او الامن العام
السعوديه عبر حسابه على تويتر القبضه على
عدد من المتورطين في ترويج المخدرات والقت
شرطه الطائف القبض على سته اشخاص لترويجهم
مادتين الانفيتامين والحشيش كما القى
الدوريات الامن في حفر الباطن القبض على
مقيم لترويجه ماده الشبو المخدره الامن
العام اعلن كذلك القبض على ثلاثه مقيمين
للترويجهم ايضا ماده الشاب والمخدر في
منطقه الرياض
كما اعلنت الاداره العامه للمخدرات في
السعوديه وعبر حسابها على تويتر القبض على
مقيم ومقيمه في محافظه جده لترويجها
مليونين او اثنين كيلو غرام من ماده الشبو
المخدر كما اعلنت القبض على مقيمين اثنين
في محافظه صبيا
لترويج اكثر من كيلو ونصف غرام من ماده
مكافحه المخدرات اعنت كذلك عن القبض على
شخص في منطقه عسير بجنوب السعوديه لترويجه
نحو 55 كيلوغرام من ماده الحشيش المقدم
مع دخول الموسم الصيف يهاجر سكان الباديه
الى موارد المياه وينتقل الحاضر لمزارعهم
يسمونها بالمجيد التفاصيل فيه تقويم مع
خالد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ما عندي خولي موسم الصيف يهجر الباديه
الصحراء الى موارد المياه وينتقل الحاضره
الى مزارعهم ويسمونها بل مقيض وهو المكان
الذي يستقرون فيه طوال موسم
وينتقل اصحاب المناطق التهميه ذات الحراره
العاليه والرطوبه الخانقه الى الاماكن
المرتفعه البارده ليش يزينون كذا لانه مع
دخول جمره القيظ يونيو ويوليو اغسطس ترتفع
فيها درجات الحراره الى معدلاتها العاليه
وتصل فيها رمز الارض الى غايته وتهب فيه
رياح السموم الحاره وهذا التنقل والارتحال
يصنع لنا النسيج الاجتماعي ويثير الاحاسيس
الحبيه وهذا ما جعل العرب يتميزون في وصف
حبهم حظيته يعود الاراكي بثغرها اما خفت
يا عود الاراكي اراك لو كنت من اهل القتال
قتلتك ما فاز مني يا سواكم سواك
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وبعد اربعين يوما تقريبا تبدا درجات
الحراره بالاشتداد بما يسمى عند العام
ابداد حتجمرت القير الجوز الاول والجوز
الثاني ذبحت القير ومدتها 26 يوما المرزم
والكليبين جمره القيظ ومدتها 26 يوما وحين
ذاك تبدا درجات الحراره بالانفراج
التدريجي ضاقت فلما استحكمت حلقاتها ولدت
وكنت اظنها
لا تفرج
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الى العناوين
روسيا واوكرانيا تتبادلان الاتهامات بشان
التفجير سد نفاياك خفك جنوب اوكرانيا
بعد نحو ثمانيه اعوام من اغلاقها السفاره
الايرانيه في الرياض تفتح ابوابها بعد
استئناف العلاقات
نحو 800 الف ناخب كويتي يدرون باصواتهم
بعد بدء عمليات الاختراع في انتخابات مجلس
الامه 2023
الجمارك السعوديه تعلن واحباط ثلاث
محاولات لتهريب اكثر من 650 الف حبه
كبتاجون
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات